dude I remember I worked at a place
called BJ's pizza REE and he and this
was a real this was a real you know
beautiful place they had pies in there
they had a little bench to sit on when
you walked inside ash it was nice and um
and one thing I really missed or one
thing I loved they had a soda machine
had everything
Pepsi mister they had sprite orange
that's when you knew you had at least
we're working at a decent shop they had
two orange soda not just the regular
[__] but anyway um and this place was
called BJ's dude blow job and it's
anybody thinks BJ's they think blow jobs
that's a given you asked 70 people if I
say BJ's what do you think of 65 people
gonna say blow jobs but this place they
said it meant Black Jacks nobody's
[__] thinking that [__] dawg nobody's
thinking Black Jacks dude unless you had
a picture of three black guys on the
side and they all had a shirt on that
said jack on then I could see that you
know but this didn't have that it was
just a um it's at BJ's pizza and the
pizza was actually it was good but it
was [__] up as well because I don't
even know the meat was real questionable
had little balls of meat and that was
what kind of meat we had if they wanted
ham they got the kind of red balls and
if they wanted burger they got the
little brown balls and dude we had one
pie you were [__] at the end you
splashed a [__] little hit of beer on
top of it people loved it like it just
you know anyway I was working then the
oven was always burning people and they
found human hair in the oven but uh but
before that you know we worked over
there and I had a mop and everything
brownish it was crazy and we would get
high and [__] sneak [__] a handful
of pudding broad during during the shift
I'd go over there and [__] and put my
hand in that pudding and go eat it in
the bathroom by myself but uh but what
I'm saying to you man is that and Here I
am
you know 20 25 to 23 years later and I'm
you know and I'm doing a totally
different trade so that's why I'm
telling you to man is you know a lot of
people I think you know you could start
somewhere and you could end up somewhere
else but I never stopped working I never
stopped working man you know I
definitely I wasn't always as productive
on my time off but I feel like I've
always had a job of some sort good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one